je vais donc vous confectionnez devant
vous ici une pizza au feu de bois allez
c'est parti angelo prix viterra et
depuis 2010 est le dirigeant de la
société bio pizza un nom qui en dit long
sur ses intentions ma conviction c'est
de travailler en circuit court de façon
à promouvoir un certain nombre de
métiers qui regroupe justement que ce
soit des agriculteurs que ce soit des
fromagers alors là je vous prépare une
pizza une régie n'a tout simplement
c'est une pizza avec de la mozza du
jambon
on y va 1 et des champignons des
recettes bio et local qui ont entraîné
angelo à s'inscrire au championnat de
france de la pizza je me suis inscrit
tout simplement parce que c'était un
petit défi personnel je me suis dit
pourquoi pas aussi
me faire connaître de cette façon là et
faire connaître aussi mes pizzas tout
simplement puisque voilà je mets
beaucoup de coeur et de passion pour
l'événement qui se déroulera les 13 et
14 octobre avec environ 130 participants
le pizzaïolo ne compte pas déroger à ses
principes absolument en tête en tout cas
les grandes lignes parce qu'après il
faut toujours travailler sur une recette
par définition chez plutôt
perfectionniste donc voilà j'essaie de
travailler les goûts et les saveurs les
mariages l'alchimie parce qu'une pizza
c'est aussi la chimie des saveurs mais
toujours en tenant compte de produits de
saison locaux pour ce faire il pourra
aussi compter sur la recette de sa pâte
faite maison dont il tient à garder le
secret et voilà la belle gemma
[Musique]